foreign
documents are the property of the SCP
Foundation and are subject to the
classification requirements and
restrictions they're in this document
may or may not contain lethal memetic
defense measures attempting to access or
disseminate this document without proper
and sufficient authorization is
punishable by Death
good afternoon everyone
my name is Dr Miller and the SCP we're
going to be looking at today is scp-7034
object class ketter disruption class eki
and risk class Danger
notice
scp-7034's description is solely sourced
from the account of senior researcher
Richard Battaglia the file will be
updated accordingly upon Foundation
access to scp-7034
special containment procedures
the exit ran purportedly leading to
scp-7034 has been temporarily barred
from public access for foundation
assessment further action is pending
discovery of a conclusive entrance to
scp-7034 or lack thereof
the foundation is conducting an ongoing
appraisal of the United States
interstate highway system in an attempt
to discern potential access points to
scp-7034 if necessary efforts May expand
to be Global in scope
information regarding missing persons
cases related to the United States
interstate highway system is to be
suppressed
description
scp-7034 is an extra dimensional space
of indeterminate length on verified
composition and unknown features
according to the sole account of
scp-7034 the space resembles a
controlled access interstate highway it
contains a single stretch of paved Road
featuring eight Lanes cordoned by guard
rails on each side other features
including those present beyond the Guard
railing are indiscernible due to a heavy
smog that lays over the area electronic
signals such as cellular service or
internet access are apparently impaded
inside scp-7034
scp-7034 is highly congested with
traffic with all Lanes occupied by
vehicles of various make and model the
length of this congestion including its
endpoint is unknown attempts to identify
these vehicles via license plate numbers
have been met with varying degrees of
success a number of automobiles align
with missing persons reports though some
are geographically disparate from the
supposed access point to scp-7034
the means by which scp-7034 can be
accessed to remain unclear the
foundation became aware of scp-7034
following The Disappearance of senior
researcher Richard Battaglia who entered
scp-7034 after emerging from a tunnel
while commuting on interstate highway
I-85 on December 3rd 2022. the taglia
established contact with the foundation
several hours into the congestion
suspecting that he was experiencing an
anomaly
addendum 7034 1. received Transmissions
the following are recordings sent from
Richard Battaglia to the foundation via
an emergency use one-way Communicator a
para technical device issued to select
Personnel in the event that traditional
communication is impossible
all right test test
okay we're green
this is senior researcher Richard
Battaglia area 179 Department of
containment now know who what the
mothership is going to be receiving this
but the emergency kit paid off
none of you can make fun of me for
lugging it around anymore okay
if this was an ordinary traffic jam uh
just disregard you can take the piss all
you want once I get back
not sure where I am I'm on my way home
to Gainesville for Christmas and it's
been a while since I was on these roads
about
I want to say an hour past state lines
I got out of a tunnel on I-85 and rolled
up to a detour like normal thinking
[ __ ] of course
but I've been stuck in traffic for it's
got to be 10 hours now
hard to tell with the fog we're moving
forward but barely
phone doesn't work pissed in a bottle
twice already I have about half a tank
full so I should be good there but
again Dr Richard Battaglia Department of
containment
I came off exit 242 on I-85 I'll keep in
touch
six in the morning
still as dark as it was at midnight
fog is not lifting either I tried to
[ __ ] I tried to roll the window down but
there's this an awful smell I don't know
if it's exhaust or what
Christ
I fell asleep a little but the raw ahead
moved forward like an inch so this
knucklehead behind me just laid on the
[ __ ] horn
cars are just building up you can see it
in the rear view
exit 242 I-85
send someone
10 o'clock
this guy not even exaggerating the sky
is still in Black I thought it was night
at first but
a kid right now you know
had a whole a whole surprise day planned
out for him since Daddy was finally
coming home from work and I know she's
been getting them excited for it too
what a [ __ ] joke
I'm tired
everyone here has to be sitting awake
with an energy drinking some old new
metal CDs I haven't listened to since
College yeah I busted out the CDs I'm
trying to squeeze my way onto the
shoulder but I don't think there is one
just a far Lane that's as packed as the
others
this guy just got rear-ended just now
must have fallen asleep or something
Jesus
he's moving forward now but wow
wow
should be fine for another few hours I
think
I stayed up longer and this caffeine's
putting work in other than that same old
same old kiddos probably up asking what
the surprise is if I had to guess Breeze
called me at least 100 times
been killing me man
Christ are you kidding me I can't even
step out of the goddamn car
exhaust fumes it's everywhere I mean
take one breath and the tears start
Welling while your lungs feel like
they're seconds away from popping as
soon as I open the door just barely so I
didn't hit the car next to me these
behind me flip their Lids honk and throw
in their hands up waving me back
how the [ __ ] is fair I mean I'm on my
way home on my break after a year of
nothing but paperwork and [ __ ] I
can't even spend time with my family and
to be stuck like this without you know
food or water or anything I I just don't
know what the hell I'm supposed to do I
don't have field experience I'm not a
soldier I can't even turn back if I
wanted to there's no room there's
there's people all around me and they
can't get out either and
uh sorry about what I think I sent last
night
I forget what I said but it's been two
days now on the DOT
I'm living off sip of water every six
hours no clue what anyone else is doing
to fuel themselves
haven't slept more than an hour before
someone lays on the horn
it's all they seem to care about just
moving forward
the part of this that really puts me up
is that if we all stepped out we'd be
able to communicate with one another and
maybe figure something out I don't know
I've never talked to people who
organized things I thought by now you
think someone would have done something
right
I gotta see if I can talk to the driver
next to me
technically
another individual the audio is largely
irrelevant or indiscernible the window
rolls up don't know if you got that but
then shouting Through the Windows for
the past few hours rolling them up and
down every few minutes to offset the
smog
guy next to me is named Michael older
guy got here off a different Highway
entirely I-70
. I'll get you his plate hold on
so we're planning something
I'm in the lane furthest to the right
and if I was able to talk to him he
could talk to the driver next to him
and so on eventually we'll have an
entire row of cars that are willing to
get out of their cars right
and maybe if we all stop the lane behind
us will too
or they won't and they'll run us down
the second the doors open worst case
scenario I have a gun
I just need this to work
I'm starving
I'm I'm scared the breeze probably
losing her mind over this
yeah it's not like you would tell her
what's happening would you
we just need this to work
so Michael got through to the person
next to him and they're getting through
to the car and they're left
we might be able to pull this off if
this is my last message I'm either a
pile of guts on the road
or I died of a pulled muscle after
sitting in my car for so [ __ ] long
but it won't be because we're getting
out of here
wow that went better than I expected
I'm laying down in the back seat right
now
finally
oh let me uh
I'm figuring out where to start
I hopped out of the car as soon as we
stopped gone in my pocket
immediately the idiot behind me slammed
on the horn but they cut that out when
they saw Michael open his door too and
the woman next to him and the one next
to her
and then eventually everyone in our row
was standing in the road
fumes choked the hell out of all of us
and scorching out there too
but no one got back in
then that row behind us funneled out
Ordinary People each of them just as
scared and tired and unwashed as the
rest of us
that was a major relief honestly
I was have expecting monsters or
something
[Music]
we weren't able to stay out in the open
for more than 10 minutes so I'm folded
in less
there's too much
but we did organize a plan
people wanted to move forward they did
so kept driving
the rest of us set our cars up in a sort
of barricade along the road leaving the
Middle Lane open for people to pass
through
such a [ __ ] relief to be able to turn
the car off and lay down in the back
seat
and uh that said there's no long-term
plan
I mean there can't be we've secured some
supplies from tractor trailers have come
by
warm water and soda but
we're screwed when it comes to anything
else
without Refrigeration or electricity
will last a few days at most
they are outside
is a problem but I'm struggling to think
of a solution
we either suffocate in a cramped car or
a choke on exhaust
problem for tomorrow
slept for the first time in days I mean
really slept
an 18 wheeler joined up and I'm
recording this while sweating my ass off
in the back
somehow it's still cooler here than it
is out there
we have a big enough space for a group
to talk at least for a bit
there's no consensus on what's Happening
Here some say it's Purgatory others
aren't convinced it's supernatural one
woman thinks it's a dream
I'm I'm trying my hardest to tell
everyone to keep their heads up
that help is coming but
it's been four days now I I don't know
if it is
I know these are going through but I'm
assuming you haven't found a way yet or
if you have you're too far back in that
gym to reach me
I'm gonna try and keep our group
together so
if you're there you'll know where to
find me
we made a pulley system from a tow truck
you can see over the guard rails there's
just a bunch of fog but
who knows what's through it my chest
it's worth a shot right boilerplate
final message you know the deal I'll be
fine
gotta get used to those fumes masks help
actually the real covered freak was
stocked up on boxes in the back of her
car
makes it a little more tolerable once we
get out of this
I'm living in the shower for the next
month
hey uh late message I know I was busy
today got lowered over the railing
it was about 300 feet of rope still
couldn't see the bottom just fog and a
smell that got worse the lower you went
hotter too if I puke three or four times
I wanted to unhook myself honestly just
fall into the mist and see where I ended
up but
I couldn't bring myself to do it
I still want to get out of here man
I love you I I mean
I love my family
I'm gonna see them again I know I will
but if I don't move forward get back on
the road I'm gonna die
I'm starving
we have some water but we're wasting our
time in this one place
to move forward
have to
[Music]
I'm sorry
[ __ ] I'm sorry I'm sorry
when they pulled me up and I told them
I told them there was nothing down there
I
could see the same realization settling
in on their faces
some people were optimistic Sharp
a number of incoming cars had slowed
down to the point where you could
feasibly ride along the far Lane without
issue
according to my car I drove
just under 190 miles in two days in
completely stagnated traffic with a
clear Road I could do that in a few
hours
maybe there was a way out the way we
came in
I took someone's motorcycle and just set
off
I rode for hours but you can't recognize
anything here no landmarks no markings
just a road that stretched on
forever no matter how far I got
I was here
but even with a helmet and a mask the
smog was too much
I had to stop and lay down twice
could have gotten killed
nothing had to be said when I got back
to the group some came out of their cars
most just stared at me through the
windows
they all wore those same tired and
helpless faces only this time even Under
The Masks there wasn't a shred of Hope
left on any of them
people are starting to leave
wondering whether or not I should follow
had a meeting in the rake decided it was
for the best
we can cooperate all we'd like but we're
wasting time we could be using to move
forward
it's not like we're not in our cars most
of the day anyways God knows how much
[ __ ] I inhaled yesterday
there's what lies ahead and whatever
sits at the end of it even if it's
nothing
I could stay here and starve
throw myself over the edge of the
railing too
I'm doing this for you Sean Bree
I love you
I'm going to see you again
he does not appear to initially notice
that the device is recording
his birthday is the week after Christmas
so oh so you get to skimp on the gifts
I always promised my wife I'd never do
that my brother was December Baby I
totally understand yeah
God you wonder how some of those other
folks are doing it
the people who didn't stop
where are they getting their water maybe
there's a little rest stop a little Taco
Bell or something honestly
if they didn't do something similar to
what we did just to refuel
and they probably didn't make it
we'll see I guess
yes we will
at least the traffic cleared up
for now yeah
that was the worst man
when I was out there I kept telling
myself that the next time I'd fall
asleep it'd be my own button right next
to my wife
hey watch those steps we only have one
case back there
[Music]
hey I'm uh finally on the road again
it came down to four of us in the group
Michael myself
and two sisters college girls we're all
riding together I'm not in the same car
you know but
we're around easier in case something
happens like if this piece of [ __ ] car
dies
her Road's clear no traffic still black
as hell but we're covering ground
we did over 400 miles today there's so
many cars parked on the sides I don't
know if they did something similar to
what we did or
or they're dead
but if they didn't have water then
I don't know what we're gonna find
I'm not
remotely prepared for bodies
and death and all of that
I never saw a man die in my 20 years at
the foundation
it's got to be a record
but all we can do is move forward there
has to be an end
I can't just
I'm gonna hold out for as long as I can
things are getting worse
saw a car in the middle of the lane the
driver was slumped over the wheel laying
on the horn
that's someone who's never going home
his family and friends are
they're going to be wondering where he
is but the last thing he said to them
was
I miss you I love you
running out of gas
and I have to hop into Michael's car or
the girls or I don't know
at night there's cars parked along the
side
no I'm I'm not gonna do that
we scavenged some food today believe it
or not someone blew the tires out on a
tractor trailer marked as a supermarket
distribution truck
whole thing was on its side in the
middle of the road
half the food was gone most of it was
rotting but
it's something
I didn't look for the driver
I'm not [ __ ] equipped to handle this
[ __ ]
one of the girls
sisters
Iliana
she killed herself before we were asleep
I was watching the cars
she just ran out of the
out of the car and jumped off inside
I didn't watched her
by the time I tried to move
she
she was over the edge
and her sister's erect now Michael's
weather
but she just did it
God damn it who cares who even cares
[Music]
I love you
good night
out of fuel
with Michael now valentina's behind us
her car's still running
poor girl yeah I told Michael what I'm
doing
who who cares and this decides him when
we make it out
I don't give a [ __ ] anymore
terrain's getting worse more crashes
some bodies that's awesome but the flat
tire in the middle of the lane I think
he was part of our group from a few days
back
tried to flag us down
but he's more weight
we're already hurting for fuel
it's not like we couldn't have helped
him Michael has a spear in the back we
have to move it from view when we get a
chance saw someone get raided the other
night for theirs
we have problems of my own like this
[ __ ] engine keeps [ __ ] sputtering
at my knees are practically cooking from
the Heat
he fired a shot at us some bastard
firing behind his car sounded like a
rifle pun
I don't know
I took out one of their tires with me
after that there's easier targets to
hold up than the guy who can fire back
unless they have a spare or take one
from someone who does they are screwed
but
that's how it is here
I feel like scum
I don't even regret what I did
that's why
hold on I have to
I have to focus
smog's getting thicker Michael's out
now we're just driving in shift instead
of parking to sleep
count my time
I love you
I miss you
[ __ ] we're out of gas
I don't know where Valentina is
I I guess we lost track of her
she was behind us a few hours ago hey
it's so hard to see with the fumes
food's all bad too
I don't know what we're gonna do
there's never a car too far away but
God damn it
I don't want to do this man
got fuel
I don't care
they would have done the same to us
I didn't hurt anyone
I wouldn't hurt anyone
just happened to be the guy with the gun
he'll give me another couple hundred
miles
as long as I don't hit that congestion
again
I think Michael wants to ditch me
he'd be [ __ ] idiot if he tried to
pull anything when I'm the one with the
gun
I don't even close my eyes around him
anymore
I don't trust him anymore
that's reasonable right
it has to be over a week and
you know two weeks I mean
I miss Christmas
I'm sorry buddy
daddy sorry
I'm gonna make it up to you
I promise
when I get out of here
I'm done
I've made enough money I'm taking my
package early and I'll spend the rest of
my life with you I promise
I promise
I'm I'm Not Gonna Let You Down ever
again
please
God please just
let me get out of this
slimy God let me get out
instead
figuring something out
foreign
Michael's car
looking out
looking out for me now for myself
there was a car right across from me
smashed the window open and threw out
the bodies
SUV with a family of five all that half
a tank left
just horrible
this corpse is on the road
bodies
track covered hard bloody bodies all
around
and no
that's not me that's not gonna be me
some of the cars are just covered in the
stuff
ahead in the grill of a pickup truck
just stuck there
I'm so [ __ ] thirsty water all around
me but I'm not
I wouldn't do that
it's getting harder to drive straight
too much [ __ ] on the road
I think I ran someone over I don't know
don't know
not thinking about it there isn't
traffic anymore there's no room for it
just burning wrecks and bodies
sometimes I pass people
I figured I
sometimes they're eating the bodies
they can die back there but not me I'm
getting out of this
I love you so much I'm getting further
than anyone else because I love you
I was gonna make it up to you
there's a massive pile of
waste in the way cars wreckage bodies
lots of bodies dozens of them
it's burning I don't know what happened
but I can't see the top
I'm gonna have to climb over get out of
the car and see what's ahead
got to the top oh [ __ ]
I passed out on the wreckage caught
myself so many times I could feel the
grease in my wounds
I got over it there's no cars ahead
nothing
they couldn't get past the pile
the fires burn through the smog
had to get in another car
had to
I'm in a car again
every second I'm just thinking or
getting home
coming out alive I should be dead by now
but I'm not
that means something to me
I'm gonna pass out
there were cars on my left
I don't know where they came from
ugh
God
what happened was the one on my left
came to a stop
driver stepped out
because he was just
I'm weak all of a sudden this tractor
trailer comes barreling out of nowhere
no horn nothing ran him right over
got splattered Wheels he was just kill
them
and if they ever do that to me
I'm gonna kill them too
some just tried to run me off the road
didn't let him do it I don't care who it
was
feels like it's just me out here
me and the bodies
there's some sort of
line in the distance it's going up
up that has to be it
through the clouds oh my God it's
something
that I'm making it out I'm not holy [ __ ]
full speed racing up this hill for an
hour now [ __ ] you all I'll be home soon
I know I deserve this thank God I know I
deserve this
I'm in the clouds now it just keeps
going higher and higher the Smoke's
clearing less black more gray this is it
this is it
roads evening out
this guy's clear I'm coming up to
[Music]
wait
that's another car
what the [ __ ]
the lanes are thinning there was well
well it's thinning into a single Lane
now
but there's cars ahead of me I can see
them now no no I'm not doing this again
now the hell did they get this far
you you you you you
Rose
the road's so thin I can't even open my
door the railing's there
This is the End right this is it this
this is it
no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no
laughs
[Music]
no transmission was received for 18
hours the longest gap between
correspondences
hello
you have to speak up
okay good
good still good
this is
senior researcher Richard Battaglia
area 179 Department of containment
I've processed that this is going to be
my last message
the smog cleared up a few hours ago and
I can see ahead of me now
there's a tunnel
at the end of the road one massive
gaping tunnel
sitting up there in the clouds
looks man-made but I know it can't be
inside is Pitch Black
can't make any details of
there's these bursts of fumes that come
from inside
and the lane you
know
we're funneling into it
my car gave out
I'm sure you can hear that noise
it's me getting pushed by whoever's
behind me just
a slow approach into whatever the hell's
in that tunnel
I already had my breakdown
punch the [ __ ] out of my window
broke my hand I think
I've just
accepted it now
that's either my way out or or it's over
[Music]
I can't fully shake the hope but
I got it
sucks
what was it all for
owes any of that effort four
article 32f of the foundation employees
rights policy in the event of certain
death while in the field Foundation
Personnel May request that there can be
made aware
details of their passing
I don't want to hear all of this but I
have enough time to
Sean
[Music]
I'm sorry that your daddy couldn't be
there for you
no excuses
I should have caught
doubt of this the second you came into
my life
I won't ever see your graduation
or your first day of first grade
or your face
when you see your sister for the first
time
I won't be I won't be there to watch
either of you grow up and that's my
fault
I love you
thank you
you can't hate me I I understand
Bree I I knew I knew
I always knew
promised me that whoever you bring
around when I'm gone loves you
treat the kids right
love you
never stop loving you
if I come out the other side I want this
burn
further communication was not received
until 1217 2022 a week following
battaglia's last message these final
Transmissions 20 in tonal will not be
played has all consisted of feedback
heavy Distortion the sound of horns and
screaming
a total of 83 000 unexplained
disappearances have been linked to the
United States interstate highway system
this concludes today's lecture
thank you for listening if indeed you
still are and you are all dismissed
goodbye
I would like to give a special thank you
to
Dr felryn
silent
tomothy
zargaron
Professor Puffer
broken sketch
Dr Wolf 13.
cubster
Spencer J tilp
well-remmer
vinyl
devios the hollow
zazapan
Lemke
Dr Briggs
tailored printers
signor
alatreon
your local Foundation agent
derivative
Lost Boy
Lyndon B Johnson
oh crop guy
the Morrigan
James Saba
and NJ vojak
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com forward slash the volgan
thank you